there's PvE servers available as well as
regular servers so we recognize that
there are players in the game who don't
want to necessarily deal with griefing
and PvP combat and so we offered PvE as
an option and that's what we're gonna be
doing today so that I can talk through
this with you guys and we don't run into
any any players looking to have a little
fun with me while I'm doing this so
let's move into the customization menu
real quick and I'll explain this really
fast so customizing in the game now
works on the fly anytime you can swap it
it doesn't matter you don't need any
special cool bench you don't need to be
in any special location you can be
anywhere in the game we offer eight
different hairstyles one of them's bald
so you obviously my hair is not poking
through my hat so you can't see it my
haircut doesn't really matter but then
we've got a large assortment of masks
that are going your face where and you
can click on these items and preview
them as well as you can put on a helmet
and so these can go in collaboration
together to make your character kind of
like dress up to however you feel fit as
well as if you're playing with your
friends and say you guys all want to be
firemen we're not going to stop you from
all being firemen now you'll notice that
some of these cosmetics are acquired 4gc
others are acquired for GD which is
zombie currency that can be acquired
in-game other ones like this brown
tanker they don't actually have an
acquisition method shown so this shows
that it isn't available cosmetic but
you're gonna have to find it through
another avenue in the game it could be a
liberation it could be another way so we
have multiple progression paths for
cosmetics for shirts same thing here
we've got quite a lot of shirts
including a lot of shirts depending on
your nationality if maybe you want to
show show some pride from your country
you can do that now and then leg wear
it's pretty pretty self-explanatory but
basically now we we really want to
encourage players to be able to
customize at any time if you're in a
desert biome we want you to dress up so
that you blend in with the desert if
you're in a town maybe you want
urban outfit if you're in darkness
you're probably gonna want something a
little bit darker but all these can be
changed at any time and once they're
unlocked they're permanent and they
cannot be dropped on death and they're
not lost they also provide zero
protection so that takes me on over to
my backpack since now that cosmetic
items you can dress however you want and
since you don't lose it on death how do
you get armor in the game so we have
this new system with our two armor slots
basically one of them as you can see
looks like a body armor and other one
looks like a helmet these are your two
armor slots and so you can take your
armor and place it in either these slots
you can be wearing up to two at a time
and it doesn't actually affect your
character cosmetically it allows you to
dress up however you want we've
basically got a new thing with cases
these are available throughout the world
you can find them either from zombies or
just looting around the train inside
they have cosmetic items that are
permanent cosmetics for weapons we also
have permanent cosmetics like some of
these that come in crates like the
plague wolf shirt that I'm actually
wearing on my character right now is a
crate item as well as we've got a
liberator case which comes from
liberating towns which I'll talk more
about in a little bit as it's one of our
new cool PvE type gameplays even though
it will attract the PvP players but
basically it works very similarly to
csgo you can basically once you've got a
case you can take a key and you can
unlock so as I kill some zombies I'll
prey into finding some cases I'll end up
unlocking a case and show you guys how
that works but once I did unlock it it's
gonna then give me a gift box these gift
boxes do not drop on death the keys
don't drop on death either and they can
be traded so in the event that say you
get a cosmetic that you already have
like I believe I've already got this oh
no I do not so it consumed it but in the
event that I had had this let's see here
here's the decimator
oh yeah okay there we go so you've
already you've already got that cosmetic
item so since I've already got this
cosmetic item it won't let me consume it
it won't drop on death and so I can then
take this to the safe zone and basically
try and trade it with another player
that's probably interested in collecting
this item we have this case even let's
show you how this cosmetic case works so
you can basically hit unlock and
you're familiar with csgo it works very
similarly to that it looks like are we
gonna get lucky almost on a legendary
almost instead of we got the black skull
shirt so what that's gonna do is that's
gonna end up putting this gift box right
into our inventory like this this can
then be traded to other players it
doesn't drop on death because it was
from a cosmetic crate and if I unwrap it
it will give it to me permanently or I
can even drop it on the ground for
another player to take so if you have
duplicates you can trade them you can
sell them to other players it's really
up to you what you want to do with them
but once you've unwrapped it it's gone
it then goes into your customize menu
let's just cruise on over here we have a
new type of loot system it's very
dynamic and that we can control
basically civilian loots military Lutz
Police Lutz Diner Lutz civilian car
versus military cars we have a lot more
control over everything that spawns in
the world as well as a lot more
available spawn points so since we're in
a civilian house right now you can see
we've basically got a scissor shank
which is a low tier melee weapon in a
box of sugar so this box of sugar right
here this is considered one of those
crafting supplies and so you can see in
the description that says this can be
salvaged for valuable crafting
components we can then salvage that and
it's gonna lump into my my supplies here
I believe I got some chemicals from that
we've got a lot of different types of
environments since this is a farm we're
also going to be exploring into towns as
well as we're gonna be exploring into
military bases and a little bit of camp
play so one thing that kind of happens
in other survival type games is you'll
you'll end up finding yourself in an
area and you want to go to another one
so say we're right here but what if we
say wanted to go to stop word city right
in the center well oftentimes you end up
having to go as the crow flies and
oftentimes what that means in survival
games is that there's nothing between
you in the next town so we've really
tried to eliminate that we've actually
got over a hundred sixty camps on the
map now that's what these green little
tent guys are scattered throughout and
basically within these tents you can
find different unique camp style loot
and actually the zombies that guard
camps have their own unique camp style
loot table zombies the guard police
Asians have their own police style loot
table the same goes for military bases
the same goes for towns and the same
goes for farms so we have five different
unique zombie loot tables you're more
likely to find ammunition on a military
zombie and you're more likely to farm or
find vegetables on a farm Sambi so
that's kind of cool so now that we've
made it over to this body of water at
the farm I'm basically going to step
with my feet into the water and so
that's going to allow me to then fill
this bottle of water right here and so
I've gained dirty water you can see then
dirty water is going to give me negative
eight health negative ten stand that's
zero hunger and it's gonna give me some
thirst but overall this is gonna end up
hurting me so what can you do with it
well I have the option to purify it
because luckily I'm carrying
purification tablets now where did those
go oh they're there so that gives me the
option to purify it if I say throw those
out of the inventory as you can see I
can just take items and I can just throw
them out by dragging and dropping now so
you don't have to just choose drop like
that you can just say I don't want it
and just throw it out Diablo style so
basically now that I've done that I
don't have the purify option so what can
I do with that if I don't have a purify
option and I haven't been lucky enough
to come across a tablet well you can use
your campfire and you can actually
purify water using a campfire by
standing close to it and using purify
option there you'll see then I have my
clean water
I can then drink it I've got another
empty bottle I can step back in the
water refill my bottle and then I can
purify it again because I'm within range
of the fire so base building now in the
game you can see there's a statue right
there as I was showing it off earlier
but that is another statue right there
and let me explain what the statues do
so basically when you have a statue now
this defines your box and inside your
box you can determine this is my area
that I own and inside of it basically
you can build objects other players
cannot build inside those objects and
other players cannot set their zones
flush to yours like this I cannot place
it right there it's not going to allow
me its to flush we don't want players
tampering with each other's bases but
once you go and place your your area and
you stake your claim basically with your
statue
you can then place other objects in
there ranging from living quarters which
this living quarter
you can place a sleeping bag inside of
it or another player could place the
sleeping bag inside of it thus allowing
them to respawn at your base if you've
got multiple living containers you can
have multiple people living out of your
base but if you if you own a base it is
also available as your own mobile
respawn you can also have a permanent
cooking rack which is a permanent fire
as well as another small survival Shack
that you can place the sleeping bag in
as well as well as larger living
quarters and even a strongbox so now
I've got my statue over here and if I
come inside here I can basically flop
down my structure really quick show you
how that works so it shows up as kind of
what I call like a bubble object and so
other players can't see this unless
they're in my group because I own it but
if another player is in my group they
can come over and they can actually help
me build this object by contributing
materials just by using the sliders and
coming over and contributing their own
supplies so that's how that works but
let's go over here and let's check out a
more full-fledged base so you can kind
of get an idea of what it's like so
we've got stilts as you can see so we
allow you to place this on any terrain
like say that you're on a hill or you
can't necessarily find flat ground I
mean there's not really a lot of flat
ground around here but if you're not
with your stilts it'll balance out and
make it a nice even area for you to to
build on so as you can see here I've
placed some farms inside the space we
can harvest these they are time-based
and so they will regrow no watering is
needed
these are our two heavier-duty objects
this one is a purified water right here
and so actually since I have my clean
water I can come over here and I can
fill it right at this spigot and always
have clean water in my base one of the
perks of being a base on it as well as
this campfire it will hurt me slowly if
I'm on it it will also cauterize a wound
so in the event that you've you've
gotten bitten by a zombie and perhaps
are bleeding and you don't have a
bandage or you can't craft the bandage
but you happen to have some wood or a
harvesting tool and you can get wood you
can then create a campfire and cauterize
your wound with it of course then after
a little bit standing near the campfire
you will be healed over time for being
near it but it will lower your liquids
speaking of things that affect your
liquids and food and water standing in
town actually your food and water goes
down slower than if you're running or
you're sprinting and also the other one
that is a status modifier is the safe
zones if you were in a safe zone we've
eliminated hunger and water we don't
feel that it's fair to penalize the
player for standing around in the safe
zone and trading or talking to other
players or taking a break and coming
back and feeling like I need food and I
need water and my characters dying it
just wasn't very fun so players that are
in safe zones now they no longer lose
food and water coming over right over
here this is a storage container if I
try and access it it's not gonna let me
because I don't own it this is owned by
another player it can be broken into
however mele it's not going to work it's
going to be impervious to melee we'd
experimented with giving these things
health values in the two and three
millions and we still ran into players
getting teams of 15 guys all together
with melee weapons to break in and so we
decided that that wasn't very fair and
now you need a good deal of explosives
or ammunition to break into a storage
container so this acts as kind of a
little home away from home because you
can spawn at it when you die or you can
spawn at your sleeping bag or you can
spawn at proximity or you can spawn near
your group leader or you can spawn in
the safe zone so this is one of the
little camps I was talking about I'm not
sure why that other icon is over there
but basically here we're gonna find
really kind of generic supplies we've
got chocolate bar there's a broken
window that's gonna be glass is broken
rocket a plastic container that can be
broken down looks like that just despawn
ran out of time I've got some firewood
here you're not really going to end up
finding super high end supplies however
I do like the theory that you know some
crazy guy some crazy ex-military guy was
living out here and you know there isn't
odds that you might find some sort of
rare pistol rare shotgun rare assault
rifle something along those lines it's
not going to happen every time of course
you're going to be much more likely to
find that in a military base but the
camps do offer kind of a nice grab bag
of loot like here we've got some
antibiotics even and a fresh tomato a
box of lard some money and cold syrup
and while it's loading I'll I'll explain
on the map the liberation system so
you'll notice on the map that basically
there's an area right here that says
zombie infested area zombies killed 0%
liberate the area by repairing and
refueling generators and killing zombies
so each of our four main cities which
are Luton cost Ville bamberg and
Stafford they each four have a zombie
infested liberation possible on them I
consider them to be tiered one through
four tier one being the easiest Tier
four being the most difficult a tier one
can be almost soloed if not soloed as
well as due owed a tier two might take
three or four experienced guys at tier
four or - sorry tier three might take
three or four or five guys and the
largest city is probably gonna take
around five to six plus guys even up
into the tens it really depends on how
coordinated players are players are very
clever and I'm sure that even though
I've said that they can be done with
those amounts of people I'm sure if
people see the video they're gonna say
Artemus I'd I did it with two players
and you know what more power to you but
show me show me how easy it is to do
with two players if there's ten other
players trying to get you so we we do
make this public as well so when players
are killing zombies here the percentages
are public and when the air drops do
come down this does turn bright green
letting players know the town has been
liberated zombies are no longer spawning
and air drops containing very nice items
are spawning those items are of course
free for all if you walk over to the
Supply Drop and another player shoots
you on it that's fair game so make sure
you protect your supply drops but some
of them nicest items in the game can
come from Liberation's you get rewarded
for liberating the town a small GD item
a GD amount as well as the liberation
box which can contain cool rare
cosmetics and so if you did a tier 4
reward town expect the supply drops to
come with epic lutes
and if you did a Luton small tier supply
liberation expect lower tier assault
rifles and things of that sort
assault rifles that don't come with
skins pistols novice
just the generic low tier armor it kind
of acts as a stepping-stone system
between tier 1 tier 2 2 or 3 and tier 4
I basically suggest players try that out
from there we've got our other 4
Liberation's on the map which you'll
notice have different icons they
actually have blue guns on them and
these are considered military
encampments and their military
Liberation's these military liberation
zyq tier is 0.5 they're much easier I've
been able to solo all of them all four
of them so I expect that players can
solo them if they're resourceful but but
ideally probably two players and so
those offer just a nice little stepping
stone and so while you're in a military
area looting like the area we're at now
you might decide hey I want to do more
than just loot the town and I want to
make killing the zombies end up being
worthwhile
well we allow you to do that now and
you're gonna get extra rewards for doing
that however you're also probably going
to attract a couple vultures who are
gonna notice hey there's somebody over
here that's liberating this so that's
one of our new really cool PvE and
counter type things that's happening in
the game that unlocks very valuable loot
I just wanted to walk through here and
kind of show you guys some cool stuff
with the way that certain areas are laid
out so you've basically tried to expand
on playable area in the game and so
oftentimes buildings will end up having
rafters and things like that and so I'm
going to demonstrate here that if you're
paying attention when you're in areas
you might notice that the upper areas
look like they have things that can be
walked on well that's because they can
and so in certain areas there might be
boxes pushed up against things and if
you start to climb up the boxes you
might find yourself in an area that you
never knew was lootable and if you go up
in here you will find goodies like
here's even a cosmetic case I've
basically tried to reward players for
exploring in the game and so areas like
this definitely have an increased chance
of a rare item compared to other more
generic areas say something that's just
on a regular table out in the open we'll
have less a chance of finding something
cool compared to an area that that is
like this that ends
having a kind of little hidden
compartment so making our way over here
this is one of the generators and so I'm
gonna kind of explain how this works
really quickly so on our UI right now
you can basically see it says zombies
killed zero percent and then there's a
little greyed out looking icon that icon
represents the generator and so walking
over the generator it says it needs a
repair and hold each refuel the
generator well I don't have a jerrycan
on me at the moment and I'm not near any
gas pumps so I won't be able to do that
I also do not have a mechanical wrench
but the wrench works very similar to the
way Team Fortress works and that you can
just whack on it and it will basically
end up repairing it over time and so you
can do that and once you get it working
that icon will turn bright yellow
letting you know the generator portion
of this liberation is complete and then
you just need to get the zombies to a
hundred percent so basically start
killing as many zombies as you can until
it turns green and it says the town has
been liberated or the military
encampment has been liberated and it
will come with a timer saying this many
minutes until your next Supply Drop
once the Supply Drop calls down you can
see it right there on your HUD it it
shows a chevron right through walls as
well as players that are on the map will
see that the town is liberated and see
that the supply drops are coming and
they will know your timers meaning your
first Supply Drop will probably be
uncontested but after that who knows
who's going to be lurking in the shadows
you